apparently Orange County Choppers is
back what's up gentlemen good morning to
you CEO Brendan I love what y'all doing
man a lot of podcast got a lot debate
club for you so I'm originally from New
Orleans Louisiana
but I do I even went down that causeway
spent my time and that's st. slam and he
you know zap now I'm in Salt Lake City
Utah so here's my debate a lot of people
here love going hiking and seeing the
mountains for what they worth and going
out there doing their thing back home
you know it's water and Gulf Coast and
seeing which you can cut up on that
Bayou so man here's my debate
what's better than Huygens in the
mountains or is it better just to chill
not by you yeah let me know what you
think figured it was a perfect debate
for y'all from where y'all from
alright let me know gang guzzle but
muzzle
that's a scary looking man at muzzle on
that boy did some time he did we think
you did broke a few necks still see his
tattoos at Louisville Slugger or price
stole some choppers for parked and he's
not even from Louisville yeah that guy's
done see look at that he prolly
definitely the boys doing the Lord's
work on the street oh yeah I'm glad he's
a fan I'll tell you that right now yeah
that dude is huh you know he drives a
hog I do this thick lush a nice ammo
line for the Utah blaze that arena leaf
is it I played for them you really did
ya bring up the you tell blaze emblem if
you can I don't think the team's there
anymore
I think they really went under but yeah
there was a team called the Utah blaze
Wow how many games you play uh I was in
a season nope I was in camp got my
Jersey and then halfway through camp I
was like wait how much they paying us I
was miserable they wanted me get to 300
pounds Wow
we still have Arizona Rattlers do you
mm-hmm yeah he chopped Utah place Boise
burn I think was a team to I think I
remember and then I remember everyone
the locker rooms they paid us I think
like
25 grand that was the most we got and
everyone was like well you know Kurt
Warner started here no I get it I get it
dude
we're doing dinner fell we're all thick
is fun is that not common for people to
go to NFL what what I mean it's over
dude Wow chapter you tall place
uh listen mayonnaise I'm uh as president
think boy bike club uh yeah pick you
talk is the thing has some of the best
trails out there in the world and I was
just on their trails that's a thing man
I mean I still have dirt all over me
from there mmm-hmm
still got the scar for sweat on it yep
this thing is a hundred percent Utah
from Utah man and its Mormon oh it's
everything out there they got polygamy
too out there and here's the thing that
they'll do I learned this is a
polygamous housing trick they will have
a a man will get a wife okay
then they will get a house for the wife
but they won't complete the house they
won't finish the building of it and if
it's not finished then they don't have
to pay property taxes on its own you can
still be a functioning house but if it's
not completely finished and you save
that money can say just save a little
bit of bank you know trip in the system
mmm and I think Mormons should be able
to have their own country if they want I
think if they basically do yeah the
Presidents Tom Cruise yeah some dough
plan they're not being a scientist
Scientology or chilling the bite another
by you though you can get bit easy
here's the problem to buy you them
Gators said I can't relax in the body
you will be a snicker out there you'd be
a vanilla snicker you're right Mormons
don't pay the taxes either though any
any religion is tax exempt Zowie they
all tie if you're right you're right I'm
still off today though boy yeah you get
snagged on out but also if you're not in
the super healthy lifestyle Utah ain't
the place
New Orleans is yeah you go to that
Bourbon Street you're that old bar where
it's all dark there's just candles you
were absurd sibel you getting free
drinks all night so you fit in there
anyway first of all to LSU collars of
all your shoe colors you get a you
saxophone in one hand you get drinks all
night so I got a saxophone [ __ ] yeah Oh
yeah you know Lisa Simpson tattoo on
your back or Krusty the Klown the way
kill me the lights out hell yeah
dude I think I love the Bayou man I love
being able to fish though that's one
thing that's in the mountains you got to
come down from the mountain to fish
because they don't have a lot of Lake in
the mountain there's some fishin though
and you told them
but those fish have to climb up the
mountain and they barely even wet when
they get up there you look kind of
dehydrated by the time they do get up
yeah they're a fish stick you might find
a couple fish deep-fried man I mean it's
just difficult race they're both great
but your boy being a biker I'm picking
you Tom yeah respect man so there's not
a lot of gang activity in like you're
not getting too much trouble in Utah
goodbye you get some Trouble Man
yeah the Bayou yeah I get my tits out
you get married down there people
killing each other a lot more every
gangling episode is in New Orleans first
48 starts in New Orleans I ask doing
that some of that method Louisiana
methis want glass they call it I think
man I'm gonna go Utah fresh out of Utah
at the moment you know I'm my own Utah
man I'm still got that elevation in my
lungs so I'm gonna stay in Utah man Utah
it'll be wait here John Burroughs a
freakin savage bra and Utah's you have a
professional football team which is
alarming
well the youth of Utah blaze but they
weren't but I'm not I'm not
you took a lake a Harlem not talking
like Hollywood you guys in Orleans
Saints and then college football the the
youth ain't bad you keep saying oh I go
to the you [ __ ] the you is unison Miami
you guys need to quit that [ __ ] Utah
you're not the real you yeah you is
University of Miami but you go down
there they do tell them it's not the
real you you get [ __ ] really
yeah but Utah State also the Cougars I
think is their team name nope Utah State
Aggies
oh wow hmm but they got some a lot of
decent schools out there BYU yeah yeah
bring um young baby BYU all Hawaiians
all white boys and they can play some
ball oh yeah there's a couple black some
why not many I said a couple is it
really good yeah from pineapple blacks
it's what they call a lot of the
Hawaiians yeah you're right
Utah has some ballers though like Alec
Smith came from there you don't happen
to expect a Smith you know happened him
I I didn't either
I was watching ESPN 60 they have that 60
show on there and so right ball for San
Fran then [ __ ] humbly came out or if
he's taking me mm-hmm Kaepernick so that
I kill he's probably the future
he went to from there he went to the
Chiefs and then he got hurt that I got
his passing my home so he's falling
patching homes then they're like all
we're all set do we got patching my
homes
he said well [ __ ] goes he goes to
Washington signs like a three-year
hundred million dollar deal six game of
the year
hut hut hike JJ Watt tackles him
compound fractures his legs and the way
he got tackled they like broke all his
[ __ ] you know standard leg injury he was
the hospital two days later they do
surgery he's like me I'm trying to get
back home that guy you can leave today
he's like I don't feel great though so
they take his temperature he has like
104 temperature and something's going on
they look in his leg he got some on the
field
cuz dirt down there you got some eating
flesh-eating bacteria they show the
pictures
it's insane dude he's done done damn oh
yeah the flesh-eating bacteria tore up
his leg so bad they were like man if we
don't decapitate his leg in the next day
or so he's gonna die so his wife was
like well then take the leg but then I
guess some medication worked and so his
legs there but it he's [ __ ]
they took my skin early took muscle from
his other leg to put on this leg Wow
yeah it's a sad story yeah who has money
though at least you know he's not dead
oh yeah hundred million a Redskins Wow
gosh so sorry the pictures broth dude
that's our breaking yeah
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]